all right ladies and Gentlemen let's
let's see let's get serious we have this
story for the New York Post is big news
Daniel Penny to surrender and face
second-degree manslaughter charge in
Jordan Neely chokehold that's right
despite the fact that we have videos
showing he tried to save the life of
this man despite the fact we know this
man had been arrested dozens of times
kidnapped a child punched an old man in
the face punched a woman in the face we
know that he was threatening people on
the train and said he didn't care if he
got hurt or went to jail
three men took it upon themselves to
subdue him this guy is going up to
surrender for manslaughter charges
up to 15 years in prison I would not be
surprised if he is convicted and
sentenced to the maximum that's it
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if he was
convicted uh I would I would hope that
the judge wouldn't send some sentence
him to the maximum but uh I don't I
would have no faith in in New York's
justice system to not considering the
pressures that would come from the
activists and the the uh the left it
more broadly he's got almost no chance
he shouldn't he wasn't initially even
charged like they had to go to a grand
jury it's not like it was they did not
go to a grand jury no they didn't they
did not go to a grand jury nope they
just decided you know I want to charge
him no that's yeah that that only makes
the uh
my opinion of the whole thing worse and
it makes my opinion of the outcome
more dire I suppose I don't I don't see
this guy getting out of it in in one
piece
pessimistic no I mean I think the only
things that are illegal in New York at
this point are political opposition
self-defense and desecrating the pride
flag right like that's the only thing
that'll actually hold you accountable
for you can't be surprised it's it's an
arco-tierney at this point the the whole
reason you're out there is you let these
people lose you let them terrorize the
average person terrorize the population
and then as soon as anyone stands up for
themselves then you go ahead and strike
them down you know for daring to you
know take care of themselves and not
rely entirely on the state it's very
clear the state's not going to do its
job it's not going to protect these
people it's only going to persecute
people who it they disagree with and
then as soon as you step up and you try
to take care of yourself you're out of
there and I I don't understand how
anyone's still living in these places at
this point it's horrific
so uh here's a quote it's it is stunning
that they would make an arrest before
presenting this to a grand jury defense
attorney and former Manhattan prosecutor
Mark betterow said Thursday following
news of the charges Bragg made a
political call he now owns this
absolutely it's political we all saw
this coming we knew it was going Kim
Potter she's the cop who the guy dives
into his car and she reaches for her gun
she thought she was tasing him she yells
taser but then shoots him and kills him
and when that happened we were like oh
she's going to prison and she did she
recently got out we do have a give send
go for Daniel Penny's legal defense fund
which is currently at 71 332 but if I
refresh it'll go up refresh now ninety
thousand dollars see this defense fund
was launched before the charges were
announced now that they've been
announced it seems that people are
flocking to it and giving this man money
and I won't
we were talking about this earlier and
I've been talking about this quite a bit
and I talked about this with Kim Potter
years ago
look I hope this guy gets acquitted I
think it's terrible what they're doing
to him but at a certain point I'm just
wondering why it is that people keep
sending their money into burning
buildings that where the fires aren't
being put out like we're talking about
the city of New York engulfed in
figurative flames and people being like
I'm gonna go walk in there and you're
like nah dude like come on seriously man
don't go in there like no I'm gonna go
in there like if you go in there you're
gonna get burned I'm gonna go in there
then they walk in start screaming help
help them on fire like I'm not gonna go
in that building I just think I think
it's it's ridiculous at this point so
here's what ends up happening
people on the right Libertarians post
liberals disaffected liberals
send money to the defense of people who
are choosing to live in places where we
know they will destroy you unjustly and
it drains resources from us it takes
money from you and that's probably on
purpose it's like the villain when the
superhero is like I'm Superman and you
can't stop me and then the Joker's like
oh yeah and then points the weapon at
the kid and then Superman's like oh no
now you've got me because I care about
other people this is what they're doing
they're holding us hostage keeping us
off base by targeting innocent people
and threatening them with 15 years in
prison but look it's tough I don't want
this guy going to jail I think he was
doing the right thing protecting other
people and clearly these two other guys
agreed with them and helped him subdue
this guy but at what point in the
passengers thanked him right and then he
tried to save the guy's life but at what
point are we going to be alike we can't
keep throwing money at people who choose
to live in communist jurisdictions I
mean you see this all the time you see
these videos and people all say why
isn't anyone stepping up you watch
someone harassing a homeless person or
some crazy person attacking people
getting island with people and they're
like why aren't the men stepping in why
aren't they taking action and this is
the answer everyone understood what was
going to happen here especially again
due to the racial Dynamic let's be
really honest this guy's white the guy
who died is black and that's all that
mattered before anything else that's all
that matter that's what everyone saw
it's what all the Liberals were acting
on and this guy had to be held
accountable because they're gonna hold
this guy up as being murdered they're
already talking about oh he's a really
kind guy he's having a lot of mental
health troubles as a you know very sweet
person who's you know performing on the
subway with Michael Jackson impersonator
no he's a violent criminal he had felony
charges out against him is very clearly
he's a threat to everyone around him the
city made sure that he was still in
public and as soon as anyone stood up to
him they're in terrible trouble I know
that people want to stay in these areas
I understand I have a lot of friends who
say we have to stay in these areas
because this is where culture happens
this is where decisions happens but at
this point I don't know how you say yeah
you have you're gonna have a family here
where you know that they're encouraging
violence and you know that it's illegal
for you to defend yourself I mean how
can you you just can't exist in this
place and culture is dying Disney is
losing scribers by the millions and your
vote doesn't matter in places like New
York City but if you move to a suburb of
New York or even you know a swing state
move to Ohio move to Georgia and go to a
suburban area that desperately needs
your vote and that's the front line of
what's going on what's Happening Now is
people are like I'm gonna choose to stay
Behind Enemy Lines and then ask you for
resources and it's just like dude
you know you know what I want to donate
to I want to donate to a small business
in Georgia right now I want to donate to
Scott Pressler I don't want this guy
going to prison but it's like how do we
have to allocate funds to a guy who's
like
captured effectively but chose to go
there and is not doing anything in terms
of winning a culture War y'all who are
in these cities I know it's hard but if
you move to Ohio and move to a suburban
area that was purple and shifted
everything red we would be winning
instead there are people who are
choosing to live in places like New York
and then being surprised is happening if
you live in New York City I mean I'm not
sure exactly how far away the corner of
Pennsylvania is but I know it's a you
know like an hour and a half or
something like that it's possible you
could move to Pennsylvania and still
work in New York if you got to stay
there but get out of the Cities I mean I
moved to New Hampshire a decade and
change ago
um because I wanted to get out of
Western Massachusetts because I didn't
want you know the laws that
Massachusetts had in Massachusetts at
the time was not nearly the place that
it is now so I mean you're in control of
your own life you can't control what
your neighbors are voting for you can't
control what the people down the street
are voting for you can control where you
live get out of City these and make sure
that you are taking care of you and your
family yeah if you think you're going to
be the person who saves Illinois or New
York or California just know that you're
liable to have this happen to you or one
of your children or to have your
children be put on puberty blockers and
taken from being mutilated in New York
City there are violent protests against
this man against him people are not
protesting for him they are Marching
violently and attacking cops because
they hate him I do not see that as a
salvageable place no one in New York
likes what he did the people of New York
like this you see the video of the woman
getting punched in the face she tells
like I take a chill pill and he clocks
are clean in the face that was two years
ago 2022 comes around they vote for it
again
what are we supposed to do
just tell them like okay keep doing it
nah look
obviously the woman got punched in the
face did not want to get punched in the
face but she'll still vote for the same
policies obviously the woman in San
Francisco who was dragged to death did
not want that to happen to her she was
robbed She chased after the people who
robbed her they murdered her her friend
was on her way to her vigil she got
mercilessly beaten and curb stomped
literally they stomped on her head on a
curb
but these people despite these things
will come out and be like I feel bad for
the perpetrator how many times have we
heard these life just come out and and
apologize for the person who victimized
them
like at a certain point these cities are
just not salvageable like and it's been
years of this so we need we need to be
on the front line winning a culture war
and that means getting your family
somewhere where your vote matters
substantially more and doesn't matter in
New York or San Francisco
are you gonna donate James
I don't well thanks for putting me on
the spot uh I don't know yeah looking at
his legal fund I I certainly I'd have to
look into it but I think it's I think
it's a worthy cause I hear what you're
saying these places are incredibly
dangerous uh if I had a family I
absolutely would not stay in New York
now I understand this is easy for me to
say because I'm not tied to a career in
a particular area but I also know people
who have moved out of cities in order to
protect their family and that's supposed
to be your number one priority the
reason in truth right if if you're a
married person well what's the point of
your career if not to support your kids
and if you have to stay in an area where
your kids are going to be harmed in
order to have your career I think it's
obvious that it's not worth it I have a
friend that I was just talking to today
that lives in in the city and he's going
to get uh trying to get a permit to
carry I'm he knows that he's probably
not going to get it in the city but he's
trying to get it for Nassau County but
anyways he uh he went and he had the
class today and he was talking to the
instructor and they were going down the
uh the list of the laws and what is and
is not acceptable or legal in in New
York work and he was totally unaware
that essentially he couldn't defend his
own life in New York He was unaware that
if he shot someone that was in his home
in his home armed if he shot them and he
didn't kill them that they would sue him
and they would probably win and that the
family even if he did kill him the
family was going to sue him has no idea
your average voter is unaware of the
circumstances that they live in so again
it's one thing to be like oh I want to
be in the city Etc you should probably
check out the laws in your area you
should be aware of the voting record of
your or the prosecution record of your
D.A before you vote for the D.A you
should probably be aware of who your D.A
is before you vote for them
um and if you're in a city it's probably
too late but when you when you actually
decide to get out and go to another
place be aware of the people that are
running so the new place that you go to
doesn't turn into the garbage place that
you left thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time